cette boutique située à montfort
l'amaury va pouvoir bénéficier d'une
aide d'urgence dans le cadre du
dispositif départemental pour soutenir
le commerce et l'artisanat une aide
bienvenue pour la gérante qui subit
toujours les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
c'est compliqué alors il ya toujours un
bon petit rythme
parce que les gens consomment vraiment
locales ici donc ça c'est plutôt bien
maintenant c'est pas pareil qu'avant
c'est pour cela que 634 commerçants et
artisans répartis dans 47 communes vont
pouvoir bénéficier de cette aide
départementale dont le montant total est
de 2,7 millions d'euros elle correspond
au loyer hors charges ou remboursements
d'emprunts immobiliers du par les
commerçants et artisans pour la période
de mars à juin 2020 on va voir avec les
commençants mon forcier effectivement
les décisions qu'on a prises sont bonnes
c'est bien d'essayer d'aider mais encore
faut-il être sûr que ça réponde aux
attentes de ceux qui sont concernés
et la réponse pour de nombreux
commerçants s'avère positive comme pour
cette gérante qui a débuté son activité
l'année dernière toute aide était
bienvenue et c'était agréable de se
sentir soutenue et concerne enfin que au
niveau commune et plus largement au
niveau région département ils se sentent
concernés par même des petites boutiques
à montfort l'amaury donc annoncé plus
tôt gaulle ce dispositif du département
a été créé en partenariat avec les
communes qui ont recensé au préalable
les établissements touchés et il y avait
un véritable besoin à montfort l'amaury
où une trentaine de dossiers a été
retenue tous ces commerçants la sombre
sont quand même sur
sur le fil du rasoir et l'aide du
département est très très agréablement
ressenti par la barre le commerce le
club
le plafond de l'aide a été fixé à 5000
euros pour les commerces et services
commerciaux frappé d'un arrêté de
fermeture administrative pendant la
période du confinement